welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and thor love and thunder released
new trailer footage to announce tickets
going on sale a promo that slanders our
man gore the godbutcher by calling him a
maniac i mean come on it's not like
christian bale has starred in any movies
talking about him that way before you
want me to [ __ ] trash him then why
are you trashing my scene but we gotta
break down these new shots because we
are finally getting some answers along
with a few new questions about this film
like if gore is the master of monochrome
why do his eyes stay orange i have
thoughts let's take a look
there's a maniac who seeks to end us all
we must do something
i'm putting together the greatest he
ever called he's my best friend yes
valkyrie we get to fight again
the guardians give me those and jane the
old ex-girlfriend judy foster jane
foster
i'm not like the other gods of kill
this new promo opens with thor
proclaiming to the people of new asgard
there's a maniac who seeks to end us all
we must do something and he makes a
speech from the deck of the viking boat
as part of new asgard being a tourist
attraction this boat called edgar that
is the north scott of the sea and a
peripheral character in the thor comics
who's often partying and drinking which
might be why this boat has a neon sign
for cocktails and dreams not the tom
cruise movie cocktail now it's
interesting that thor says a maniac who
seeks to end us all when from what we
understand gore only wants to end gods
and demigods so are all asgardians the
same god status of thor and odin i would
say the great warriors among the
asgardians maybe but the lowlier
refugees who are on the run during
ragnarok who have now resettled on earth
i just doubt gore's grudge extends to
them furthermore many of the residents
of new asgard aren't even from the
original asgard their gladiator escapees
from sakaar as we saw one of korg's crew
from sakara lumbering about the docks
when hulk and rocket arrived in end game
so really thor is making gore's threat
to be more of an existential threat to
the full colony than it might actually
be really it seems like gorgeous has a
personal grudge but that said this still
tells us a lot about thor and the role
gods like him play in the mcu thor views
himself as the center of his universe no
surprise but we're increasingly learning
that as guardians as a race are beings
who derive their identities from those
who believe in them the ancient norse
societies worship gods who looks like
viking kings therefore those are the
forms odin and thor took this could be
what odin meant by asgard is not a place
it's a peephole so an attack on thor is
in a way an attack on all the people who
believe in his divinity and vice versa
i've also speculated that the pantheon
of gods the mcu might be the original
suppliers of the infinity stones which
provides the spectrum of color to the
universe radiation that despite the
stone's atomization continues to course
through the universe as cmbr cosmic
microwave background radiation that's
what wanda harnessed to create the hex
barrier in one division and that
radiation activated monica's photon
powers and now as gore kills god after
god that divine cosmic energy dwindles
resulting in everything desaturating
into grey tones but when thor uses
stormbreaker to clash into gore's sword
later in this promo thor shifts into
amazing looking neon technicolor and
you'll notice it's 2d almost like a
comic book splash page it looks so cool
in fact the imagery might remind you a
lot of monica's cmbr transition and it's
because this is a battle to save color
and life across this universe but while
we're on this note a new shot of gore
shows him talking to thor everything in
the shot black and white except gore's
orange eyes why do they retain their
color and why are they the color orange
well not too galaxy brain all of this
through some infinity tinted glasses but
if gore's desaturation is a visual
antithesis to infinity stone cosmic
radiation could there be a connection
between gore and the infinity stone we
know the least about the orange soul
stone of all the stones only the soul
stone requires a creepy blood sacrifice
of someone you love and i am plunging
deep into theory corner here so go with
me the reason why the acquirer of the
soul stone has to sacrifice someone they
love is that it might have been a
vicious curse that was initiated by gore
a guy who lost his wife aura and all of
his children but had one son left over
agar a son that in the comics he
promised that starvation would end
because they would find some bountiful
forest a forest that they never found so
i'm wondering if his decision to
sacrifice agar abraham and isaac's style
except in this case no god intervened to
stop that sacrifice that moment could
have been how gore first gained cosmic
power the power to slay other gods and
left behind on vormir a curse where any
other future holder of the soul stone
has to follow in his footsteps now we
all make sacrifices maybe you watch that
crime procedural with your partner
because they sat through your 14-3 watch
avengers end game with you one thing you
should never sacrifice is good sleep
thanks to helix you can get the mattress
made just for you so you don't need to
sacrifice any precious shut-eye helix
sleep makes premium mattresses and
bedding customized to fit your needs and
shipped right to your door helix is a
sleep quiz that matches your unique body
type and your sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you you can even
take it with a partner that's a perfect
compromise between your preferences i
took the quiz and got matched with the
dusk luxe helix mattress because i
wanted a medium firm mattress with
lumbar support that sleeps cool i've had
it for a few months i absolutely love it
i sleep better and i wake up less often
than i used to in the middle of the
night helix delivers your mattress right
to your door for free it comes rolled up
in a surprisingly small box and it's
super easy to set up by yourself helix
has a 100 night sleep trial so you can
get more than three months to make sure
that you love it and if you don't love
it they're gonna pick it up for you and
you'll get a full refund and these
mattresses also have a 10 year warranty
that is an entire decade
[Music]
helix even has financing options and
flexible payment plans so a great night
of sleep is never ever ever ever far
away i love my helix and i think you
would too if you're looking for a new
bed check out helix you can click the
link below or go to helixsleep.com
rockstars and get up to 200 off your
helix mattress now in the comics gore
actually acquires all black the necker
sword when no the symbiote deity and
another god crashed into his planet when
they're in the middle of a fight
enraging gore because he had assumed the
reason the gods didn't answer his
prayers to save his family was that gods
didn't exist and now that he knows they
do he loses it and bonds with the necker
sword and uses it to begin his god
hunting days and that gore home planet
in the comics never gets named but who
knows maybe in the mcu it could be
revealed to be vormier i mean vermeer's
barren rocky terrain and gnarly eclipses
just scream gore the orange eyes could
mean gore's got soul and goriza soldier
now moving on right before the edgar
takes off we see thor's two goats who
are also from norse mythology of course
and are now confirmed to actually be
named tooth grinder and tooth nasher one
has whiter fur the other darker fur and
spiraled horns if you listen closely
they scream
i love this as someone who has watched
endless videos of goats screaming like
people cold hot
[Music]
cork has become their handler wearing
heavy padding in a belt buckle with a
goat's head now teeth bearer and teeth
grinder are their names in mythology but
in this context tooth grinder and tooth
nasher could just be the nicknames korg
has given them after they have bitten
his arms in the town hall thor pitches
putting the team together and on escape
you can see burns and stains presumably
from his battle with the black
berserkers the night before the black
berserkers being extensions of the
symbiote all black the necker sword what
is it about phase four avengers getting
their red capes burned and stained like
this thor and korik high five but this
colorful garden background looks a lot
like the floral background behind gore
in the shot of him before his scarring
in the past trailer as he vowed all gods
will die i'm wondering if he'll say this
upon his arrival to olympus and his
initial assault on the gods root shows
up now and on binoculars during that
battle rocket now has a piece of wrist
tech that i don't think he's had before
remember bruce spanish showed up in the
shong chipos credit scene hollow
chatting with the other avengers he also
had a piece of wrist tech we know rocket
was part of that avengers group chat and
endgame this might be how he stays in
touch with the avengers of earth behind
both of them is that red-leafed wisdom
tree atop the mount that thor had been
meditating on when he started this
battle in the shot of jane from the side
this is part of the sequence which she
lands in the chamber with the statutes
of the cosmic entities living tribunal
the watcher death eon and infinity now
from that pedestal behind her you could
see some dust or some other particles
falling in other videos i pointed out
how the head of the living tribunal
statue seems to rotate from shot to shot
so that the uncovered face that of
equity faces rightward at one point but
in another shot the half-covered face of
revenge seems to be in that place and
now this movement behind jane is just
further proof that these might be moving
heads that are actually physically
talking to her i'm wondering if the
power ups of gore and if jane might be
linked in this movie from the same
source the cosmic entities that bless
jane to stave off her cancer and give
her mjolnir might be the same beings
that bless gore to stave off his
suffering maybe with the soul stone and
vermeer i'm not sure about that yet just
my theory but ultimately equipped him
with this sword however gore out of
anger may have turned on them forcing
them now to seek out jane to help them
which would make this chamber an
actuality say it with me obi-wan and
boromir it's a tomb i just think it
makes story logic sense for jane and
gore to be thematically linked like that
just to make it hard for thor to kill
gore as it may mean killing jane too or
dooming her to a lack of cancer and
taika waititi did say gore scored great
with test audiences who viewed him as
super sympathetic i think this character
is gonna be terrifying but also make us
feel really really bad let me know your
thoughts on all these theories follow me
on instagram and twitter at eavos
following rockstar subscribe to new
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you'd love thanks for
watching bye
[Music]
you